[MUSIC PLAYING]
CLAIRE SLATTERY: Hello, and
welcome to public speaking
pro-tips with Speechless,
presented by Google Developers.
We help people turn the
mundane into the memorable.
ARJITA SETHI: Challenges
into insights--
CLAIRE SLATTERY:
--and presentations
into performances.
ARJITA SETHI: Today, you
do that with something we
call taking agency,
giving yourself
permission to do what you need
to make yourself comfortable.
CLAIRE SLATTERY: We'll
give you our top three
tips on how to empower
yourself before, during,
and after your meeting,
video, or talk.
ARJITA SETHI: Let's jump right
in with my favorite tip number
one, the power stance.
You may have heard
about this before,
but it's such a
great, simple exercise
that you can do in
less than a minute.
You can see Claire getting
into her power stance.
It's a stance that gives you
a feeling of power, almost
like a superhero.
CLAIRE SLATTERY: I'm
pretty proud of this one.
How about you, Arjita?
Nice.
ARJITA SETHI: The
first time you do this,
it might feel
awkward or strange,
but let your body and
mind sink into the stance.
You have to hold it for
at least 20 seconds.
CLAIRE SLATTERY:
This gives your mind
a chance to flood your body
with strong and healthy pathways
that lead to a feeling of
strength and confidence.
ARJITA SETHI: We often
liken it to smile therapy.
Check out the description
below for a link
to get some great
articles about that.
But basically, it
is a proven theory
around increasing your happiness
quotient by forcing yourself
to smile for 15
minutes every day.
CLAIRE SLATTERY: And
we're doing the same thing
with your confidence by
striking and holding this pose.
ARJITA SETHI: I'll do this
right before a meeting.
CLAIRE SLATTERY: Or
backstage before starting
my presentation.
ARJITA SETHI: And on the
set before a video shoot.
Notice, that I'm
doing my power stance
in plain sight of the crew.
This is also sending
a message that I'm
going to do what I need to
make myself comfortable.
CLAIRE SLATTERY:
And that's the key
to taking agency, doing what you
need to do for yourself to be
comfortable and confident.
So what's another tip, Arjita?
ARJITA SETHI: Tip number
two, explore the space.
CLAIRE SLATTERY: 10-4 Houston.
ARJITA SETHI: Not outer
space, Claire, but rather
the environment where you're
going to have your meeting,
shoot your video, or
give your presentation.
CLAIRE SLATTERY: Roger, Roger.
And here's how we do that.
I walk the floor of the
stage and really take it in.
ARJITA SETHI: Or the
floor of meeting room.
CLAIRE SLATTERY: Or the set.
This is your chance to
just get comfortable
in the room, notice
where the lights are,
the audience, if there is one,
and your relationship to them.
We'll go over more of that
in the next video too.
ARJITA SETHI: Right.
So it's time for
tip number three.
Remember your mantra.
CLAIRE SLATTERY: In our
elevator pitch exercise
from video number two, we
ended with a quick one word
summation of your talk.
That word is the key
to your presentation
and should be felt by you
and your audience as well.
We call it your mantra.
ARJITA SETHI: Your
presentation, talk, or video
isn't just about information.
You want your audience
to feel something.
So when we have
our mantra word, we
can use it to remind
ourselves of that feeling.
By repeating that word out loud,
we allow it to really sink in.
CLAIRE SLATTERY:
And we encourage
you to choose a descriptive
word for your mantra.
ARJITA SETHI: You know
like an adjective.
CLAIRE SLATTERY: Like amused.
ARJITA SETHI: Or alarmed
CLAIRE SLATTERY: Or excited.
ARJITA SETHI: Then
repeat that word out loud
and really let it take hold
before you give your talk.
Give it a shot, Claire.
CLAIRE SLATTERY: Excited,
excited, excited, excited.
ARJITA SETHI: I
think she's ready.
OK.
Let's recap.
Tip number one, power stance.
And tip number two,
explore the space.
And finally, tip number
three, remember your mantra.
CLAIRE SLATTERY:
Remember your mantra.
ARJITA SETHI: She
said excitedly.
Thanks for watching.
CLAIRE SLATTERY: And as always,
check the description below
for links from Google
Developers, Women Techmakers,
and for more tips
from Speechless
on how to think
like an improviser
and develop your voice.
[MUSIC PLAYING]